in a previous video we've already shown
that if we have some circle centered at
oo right over here and that if OD is a
radius and it's a radius that bisects
chord AC so bisects means it's kind of
splits it into that a B is equal to BC
we've proven in a previous video that
this that OD will be perpendicular to AC
so so we've proven that we can assume
that it's perpendicular what and that
video if you want to look it up and you
might want to prove it yourself just out
of interest but the video if you do a
search on Khan Academy for radius is
perpendicular to chord you'll you'll
hopefully find the proof of that what I
want to do in this video is go the other
way if we know that OD is a radius and
that it is perpendicular to chord AC
what I want to do in this video is prove
that it's bisecting it so we're not
assuming that it's bisecting it in this
video right over here we're just
assuming that it's perpendicular so
we're essentially going to go the other
way here we started with the fact that
it bisected and we established that they
were perpendicular that was in the
previous video now we're going to start
with the assumption that they're
perpendicular and then prove that they
bisect and just like we did in that
previous proof we'll set up some
triangles here since we know a lot about
triangles now and we'll set up the
triangles by drawing two more radii
radii o radius OC and radius o a and
that's useful for us because we know
that they're both radii for the same
circle so they have to be the same
length the radius doesn't change on a
circle so those two things are the same
length and you might already see where
this is going because triangle oh and
let me let me label this point here let
me call this M because we're hoping that
it ends up being the midpoint of AC
triangle am o is a right triangle this
is its hypotenuse a o is its hypotenuse
triangle om C is a right triangle and
this is its hypotenuse right over there
and so we already showed that the
hypotenuse is have the same length and
both of these right triangles share
share segment or side om so om is
clearly equal to itself and in a
previous video not the same video there
where we explained this thing in a
previous video where we talked about and
I think you can look it up it's I think
it's the video is called more on why SSA
is not a postulate in that video we said
that SSA is not a postulate so s
ese not a congruence postulate not a
congruence postulate but we did
establish in that video that our SH is a
congruence postulate and our SH tells us
tells us that if we have a right
triangle that's where the R comes from
if we have a right triangle and we have
one of the sides are congruent and the
hypotenuse is congruent then we have two
congruent triangles and if you look at
this right over here we have two right
triangles a mo is a right triangle CMO
is a right triangle they have one leg
that's congruent right over your mo and
then both of their hypotenuse is are
congruent to each other so by our SH we
know we know that triangle we know that
triangle a mo a mo is congruent to
triangle see mo see mo by by our SH by
the rsh postulate and so if we know that
they're congruent then their
corresponding sides have to be congruent
so based on that we then know that a am
is a corresponding side let me do that
in a different color
a a.m. is a corresponding side to MC so
we know that a.m. a.m. must be equal to
MC because their corresponding sides
these are corresponding sides so
congruence implies that these are equal
and if those are equal then we know that
OD is bisecting AC so we've established
what we need to do another way that we
could have proven it without our SH is
just straight up with the Pythagorean
theorem we know we know already from we
already know just by setting up these
two radii right over here we know that
Oh ay OH ay so let me draw a little line
here this is another way that we could
have proven it we already know that oh a
is equal to OC and we also know that om
is equal to itself
om is equal to clearly equal to o M it's
equal to itself and we also know from
the Pythagorean theorem that a.m. is in
a new color
we know that a M Squared a
M squared plus Oh M squared plus Oh M
Squared is equal to oay squared is equal
to oay squared the squares of the
lengths of this of the two legs squared
summed up is equal to the length of the
hypotenuse squared so we know that for
the left triangle right over here for am
oh and we can do set up the same
relationship for cm oh we know in cm oh
that and I'm going to try to do it
corresponding that cm squared see M
squared plus o plus Oh M squared plus Oh
M Squared is equal to OC squared oh oh C
squared now we know a few things we know
that Oh a is equal to OC so for example
right over here where we have oay
squared we could replace this with OC we
could replace this with OC and then you
could already see where this is going
you can already see that cm and a.m. are
going to be the same but if you want to
do it a little bit more formally you can
subtract om squared from both sides of
this equation and you'd get a M squared
a M Squared is equal to OC squared I've
replaced this with OC squared - om
squared so that's on the left hand side
right over here and then on the right
hand side if we subtract om squared from
both sides we have cm squared cm squared
is equal to OC squared - Oh M squared
and then we could take the principal
root of both sides of this because we
really care about the positive root
because we don't want to have negative
distances so if you take the principal
root of both sides this becomes a M is
equal to the principal root of that and
we also get that cm is equal to the
principal root of that well these two
quantities are the same so a.m. must be
equal to CM so a.m. must be equal to CM
they both equal to this quantity right
here so am is equal to CM and it might
be a bisector and this is really common
sense if you know that two sides of two
different of two different right
triangles are going to be congruent to
each other you can always use a
Pythagorean
theorem to get the third side and that
third side is uniquely constrained by
the lengths of the other two sides
because it's a right triangle and so
these are all ways of really getting it
the same thing but now we can feel
pretty good about the fact that if oh if
OD is perpendicular here there's
definitely going to bisect this chord